seit gut einem jahr erkundet die
japanische sonde hayabusa zwei den
asteoriden riu 300 millionen kilometer
von der erde entfernt 2020 soll die
sonne dann zur erde zurückkehren und
gesteinsproben mitbringen doch schon
jetzt gibt es neue großartige
erkenntnisse zu dem gruseligen brocken
denn die ersten bilder der ausgesetzten
an der sonne mascotte wurden ausgewertet
so bekommen wir zum beispiel wichtige
hinweise darauf wie wir solchen erdbahn
kreuzen wie im fall der fälle begegnen
könnten und es fehlt etwas klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierend ist heinz videos abonniert
den kanal und aktivität glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen der 900 meter große erdgas
sowie juden heißt nicht umsonst so
benannt ist er nach dem ort eine
japanische legende in der ein fischer
mit einem schatz voller geheimnisse aus
dem palast des drachenkönig zurückkehrt
auch die japanische sonde hayabusa 2
soll schätze liefern und zwar gesteins
fragmente von riu im oktober 2018 hat er
das landemodul mobile service cloud also
kurzem escort erste aufnahmen der
soliden oberfläche an die erde gesendet
übrigens wurde die eingesetzte kamera
mesz camp vom deutschen zentrum für
luft- und raumfahrt dlr in köln
entwickelt und 17 stunden hatte sie
während des abstiegs des länder zeit um
die umgebung aus nächster nähe zu
fotografieren ein astronomie team aus
berlin hat die bilder jetzt detailliert
ausgewertet
die bilder zeigen das riu aus mindestens
vier verschiedenen gesteinsarten besteht
die helleren bruchstücke haben er glatte
kanten und oberflächen die dunkleren
brocken dagegen erscheinen
unregelmäßiger in ihrer form ein
bisschen erinnern sie an die form eines
blumenkohl in der gesteins matrix eines
dunklen felsen sind helle einsprengsel
zu erkennen manche dieser mineral körner
sind knapp einen zentimeter groß zwei
verschiedenen farben der einschlüsse
sind erkennbar nach vermutung der
fachleute handelt es sich bei manchen
der helm generale um das silikat uni
wien
es kann sowohl im basischen als auch in
sauren magnetischen gestein entstehen
und hat einen hohen schmelzpunkt auf
unserer erde lässt sich uni wien unter
anderem in einigen orten der eifel und
dem 7
die bürger in italien und beispielsweise
auch in österreich norwegen und auf
hawaii finden doch warum setzt sich der
asteroid aus verschiedenen gesteinstypen
zusammen fachleute haben auf diese frage
noch keine eindeutige antwort eine
mögliche erklärung könnte sein dass roo
aus zwei vorläufer objekten entstanden
ist die miteinander kollidiert sind
möglicherweise ist der erdgas sind aber
auch auf eine andere art und weise
entstanden nämlich durch die ansammlung
mehrerer trümmer diese könnten sich in
den anfängen des sonnensystems aus einem
deutlich größeren himmelskörper gebildet
haben kurz gesagt bei juden handelt es
sich um einen gruseligen brocken und das
ist eine enorm wichtige erkenntnis dazu
ralf jaumann vom deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt würde oder ein
ähnlicher hast du ihn der erde einmal
gefährlich nahe kommen und wir müssen
versuchen ihn abzulenken
dann sollten wir sehr vorsichtig mit ihm
umgehen denn wenn wir zu fest auf den
draufhauen zerfällt der ganze eine halbe
milliarde tonnen schwere assault in
unzählige bruchstücke dann prasseln
lauter tonnenschwere einzelteile auf die
erde tatsächlich kommt roux der erst mal
ziemlich nahe seine bahnen verläuft
parallel zu ihr und ernährt sich bis auf
eine distanz von rund 100.000 kilometern
allerdings mit einer geringen neigung
eine kollision ist nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich die analyse der bilder
hat zudem weitere details zu der
zusammensetzung von ryu offengelegt
wasser gibt es auf dem asteroiden
demnach nur in spuren denn sonst hätten
sich die mineralien gestein nach ansicht
des forschungsteams längs verändern
müssen
rätselhaft dagegen erscheint die
erkenntnis dass staub auf rongo komplett
fehlt das forschungsteam hat dafür
bislang keine erklärung denn eigentlich
müsste staub aufgrund des beschlusses
des asteroiden mit mikrometeoriten über
milliarden von jahren zu finden seien
möglicherweise ist der staub ins all
entwichen
bedingt durch die geringe schwerkraft
von nur einem 60.000 der erde oder aber
er ist einfach in hohlräumen
verschwunden
davon gibt es wohl einige zumindest des
trios geringe dichte von
durchschnittlich 1,2 gramm pro
kubikzentimeter darauf schließen dazu
das forschungsteam aus berlin in der
aktuellen studie die es gibt einen
hinweis auf komplexe geophysikalische
prozesse auf der oberfläche dieses
kleinen hast du ihn experten und
expertinnen vergleichen die
zusammensetzung von rührung
mit einer besonderen klasse von
meteoriten diese stark kollegen schon
trinken sind wirklich urtümlich sie
haben sich seit der bildung des
sonnensystems kaum verändert solche alt
meteoriten wurden auch an einigen orten
der erde aufgespürt und auch der wohl
vor etwa 4,5 milliarden jahren
entstanden ist war seitdem einzig und
allein dem sonnenwind ausgesetzt seine
oberfläche wurde nur deswegen verändert
weil seine oberflächentemperatur um bis
zu 100 grad celsius schwankt eine
weitere neue erkenntnis ist dass der
gast wo zu den dunkelsten objekten im
sonnensystem gehört denn er reflektiert
lediglich 4,5 prozent des sonnenlichts
viele spannende details also zur eu
die uns die neue studie liefert
weiterhin gibt es natürlich auch noch
viele offene fragen
doch die fachleute sind optimistisch
dass diese spätestens nach der rückkehr
von maja buße zwei im jahr 2020
beantwortet werden können denn mit an
bord wird die raumsonde hoffentlich
gesteinsproben haben die uns weitere
erkenntnisse zu der frühzeit des
sonnensystems liefern
dinosaurier großes asset anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren nämlich den
sehr coolen kanal us vogue hommes ist ev
liebe grüße von ihr
bis dann bleibt dran